I understand that Mr. White is a high-class inn. I
wonder if he was serious about holding Tamata Nagi over his head.
However, it would be a waste if it was a beautiful woman's invitation, and he
only gave one to a strange woman.
So what's the point? Excuse me.
I'm sorry to have kept you
waiting. Who are you? People often
say that you can change your appearance with make-up. People
say that too often.
But when you call me again, I want to
go back to my parents' house.
Actually, I don't know what this means.  I heard that she was
coming
home to perform at Noh.She asked me to vouch for myself in Wuhan because of her status as a woman.Yes, she
called me out of the way for that purpose.Yes,
she is strong, or rather, daredevil.In other words,
I am a chan.  I'm thinking of a way to thank you for making
good use of it on my way back home.You're kidding me,
how about some flowers when I summon you?It's been a
year's worth of discussion.If you're worried, just
show me this introduction page and you'll understand.
[Music]  Is
n't it the 3rd princess that I can't get my hands on easily
? If you don't believe me, I can't
help it. I'm sorry, I took your time. I'm very sorry, but I'm going to focus on others, so this
story never happened. And
this woman and others.  I wonder if Kurenai has a
clue, and Kantaro is clearly better than me because of the crystal and Venus.If
this girl is someone, then this story is too
suspicious.But if it's true, I'll
never have the chance to meet those three princesses again.  What should I
do?
[Music] It's
my loss.